[Music]
today we're gonna play never have I ever
let's see how gross we have been or not
never have I ever
sniffed my big toenail no they're like
your toe clipping this is a very obvious
devil
you both have never sniffed your baby in
it why do you want to smell it
I'm curious and do they smell nice no it
smells disgusting number two never have
I ever looked at the toilet after
pooping yeah it's important to cuz
they'll tell you a lot about your body
you also want to come out like fairly
solid and smooth it's like a long poop
yeah in one single mess yeah I'm gonna
text it to my sister your buddy poop and
never have I ever eaten boogers after
the age of 15 I think like 15 is really
high and you have you have you have yeah
going into high school I've seen kids in
like middle school eating boogers no
sometimes when people start lying
masturbating but five is all theirs
never have I ever farted in public yeah
everyone everyone parts sometimes you
just got a hold of it and it's not good
to hold it in
that's so uncomfortable I just crop dust
it when I used to wait tables
I used to fart tell you if I didn't like
it table was
what a very smart house
oh my gosh is Maxim's weird left scam
marks and a significant others or
friends bathroom I truly have not
because I go out of my way to make sure
it's gone yeah yeah I like demo flash if
it's there I will not leave until I'm so
considerate the point I make sure it
smells fine before I leave so I wash my
hands like three times that I'd smells
Sophia I also try to distract people
when I get back in the room so they
don't think about all the aftermath the
words is when somebody goes in it oh my
god what is that and you just throw the
whole friend group away you never go
back never have I ever showered after
pooping without wiping in between is
that we showered so you poop in the
shower I've thought about it but I just
feel like it's that feeling of standing
up it's so dry before I go shopping what
if you had a piece fair still get it out
of the shower shower probably poop in
your shower every time you shower but
not an actual physical poop it'll be
alright
do you not clean between your ass cheeks
Michelle you're doing two things
I do my thing at first half you're
wasting paper
I've definitely showered after taking a
poo that's the most eco-friendly than I
do I'm proud of you Ryan I never have I
ever eaten the extra food gathered
during class things like that extra
stuff oh you you couldn't no I don't I
don't do that I have oh it was in my
mouth before so back to the [ __ ] analogy
you have no problem consuming something
that was decaying in your mouth just
like whatever you flossed out that day
it's rotten food in the community I
don't eat it all the time but god forbid
you but I haven't eaten it before I can
see that like if it actually like went
in your mouth instead of staying on the
floss and yeah so spitting out just like
slowly I mean I still haven't butcher a
warrant underwear inside out and set up
washing you know absolutely
[Music]
then clean disgusting it's clean
no it's not now you have that on your
pants but it's dried what is dry wait if
my underwear has poop on it I would not
like where it gets yeah when I say dry I
mean vaginal discharge when it's dry
[Applause]
what thing is that happen about like
that no never have I ever pees in the
sink if I met my friend she only has one
bathroom and sometimes someone's in the
shower
I have to pee when I wake up in the
morning so I always go to the kitchen
sink you think of all the dishes and
stuff they are in this thing what I'm
doing it's like an empty thing would you
pee in the sink if you could if I could
aim I would say but not the kitchen I
clean this exactly what doesn't do
something like that's gonna help
you're so pretty whatever never have I
ever not washed your hands after going
to the toilet I have but we win I didn't
have the playability - it's okay I don't
know why I'm defending it as if you do
I'm in the same boat you bought her like
ya know especially here if you do
politically what does it matter
yeah I feel like I just out of laziness
or just feel like you're clean but in my
defense sometimes the bathrooms are
gross and you don't want to touch a sink
that's true okay last one is something
off the floor that has visible
I have not there's somebody see dust to
it that's not going in my mouth even the
five-second rule no that's an easy no
hair doesn't freak you out though one of
the people I get hair in your food
memory for I'm a damn well people's hair
exactly fairly clean
I think we're people who do gross semi
gross thing at my birthday we just have
different standards yeah like your poop
thing and my underwear thing I don't
understand why you would touch poop of
your fingers you were in the shower and
it's getting washed away anybody do that
is Amelia truster you do your thing Ryan
you do you hey my butt clean so is mine
I don't know gross stuff yeah
[Music]